i think it's fun to be a little playful
and do something people won't normally
do with something like a donut hi i'm
alexander and i'm going to show you how
to make some of my signature animal
donuts
so you'll start with your dry
ingredients your flour sugar salt baking
powder baking soda you'll whisk those
all together with your hands you can
just break in the butter until it's
practically invisible until you can no
longer see large chunks a few years ago
i found myself living in paris i didn't
speak very good french so i was having a
hard time finding a baking job much to
my chagrin if you feel chagrin it means
you are embarrassed or distressed as a
result of failure
i decided i would try to do my own
project so i started a crowdfunding
campaign for what i wanted to be a donut
cart so basically i had a tricycle with
a huge box on it and a chalkboard and i
would write my flavors on there and just
pull up in the street illegally and sell
my donuts on the weekends since i was
doing a crowdfunding campaign i wanted
to make something that would maybe be
like instagramable or you know get me
noticed apart from other crowdfunding
campaigns and i'm also in love with cats
so i thought why don't i combine like
two of my favorite things and make a cat
doughnut so i tried a few different ways
and i settled on a really simple design
since the cat donuts were so popular i
decided to try a few other animals like
a bear and a dog and frogs if you aspire
to be a baker or a pastry chef one thing
you should know is that it's all about
repetition so you'll do the same thing
hundreds and hundreds of times but
there's some beauty in that
for the cat i'll just cut away a tiny
chunk a small triangle at the top of the
donut to make ears for the dog i'll use
the same cutter i use for the middle of
the donut and just cut away a little
cheek to make like a snout and some
droopy ears for the bear and the frog
they're actually the same design but
we're going to decorate them differently
and we're just going to use donut holes
as the ears so we don't have to waste
anything you can just attach them with a
bit of water or egg white or milk when
you're frying the donuts it's going to
be about a minute on each side and you
don't want to flip it more than once or
it's going to get oily when they're
ready they'll have a very prominent
golden brown color so i'm going to make
just a classic vanilla glaze with some
powdered sugar honey and milk make sure
you sift your powdered sugar for the
glaze or it'll end up clumpy you can
flavor it with anything like fruit juice
and you can color it any color you want
it to be when i began baking
several years ago i always thought like
a donut was super hard to make and it
was like the mark of a good baker which
is not necessarily true it is scary to
fry them but they're pretty easy to make
especially cake doughnuts you don't even
need a mixer the first time i made
donuts i actually forgot sugar so when i
went to fry them they were basically
biscuits oops
i think i became obsessed with donuts
when i was younger me and my family
would go get donuts at this place on the
boardwalk every summer they were like 50
cents each they would melt in your mouth
you'd get them in a bag all melted
together and they were amazing so i'm
just gonna judge these up with a little
bit of melted chocolate and give them
some cute faces i'll draw some little
ears on the cats and their eyes and
whiskers the dogs will get some bigger
ears and some little freckles on their
snout
the bears will fill in their ears just
little circles and give them a little
smiley face and then the frogs will use
a little more white glaze to make like
an eyeball and then we'll wait for that
to dry before we put a little more
chocolate on there we're gonna do a
smiley with the chocolate also and with
some of the leftover pink glaze i'm just
gonna pipe some small tongs on them my
favorite part about making donuts is
giving them to people and seeing the
look of joy on their face
i hope you'll love these adorable donuts
as much as i do you really don't have to
be a professional baker to make
something great to share with your
family and friends
[Music]
so good
oh yes
you